[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis merci voix
[Musique]
alors ça fait du bien d'entendre et de
voir nos danses et musiques
traditionnelles
quand on voit la nouvelle génération ce
qu'on attend comme musique
alors là ça fait chaud au coeur et
c'était magnifique
[Musique]
est ce vraiment de couture détenus
étaient formidables pour la martinique
dans tous ses états on a voyagé
fortement voyager à ramer à trouver tous
les âges toutes les prestations c'est de
votre culture
[Applaudissements]
voilà deux heures de spectacle non-stop
avec plein de couleurs ils ont replié
lancement de tableau vraiment magnifique
magnifique je crois que les gens qui
sont pas venus déjà cité foule
je crois que même si il aurait dû faire
un deuxième un deuxième spectacle serait
ôté aussi bien et franchement
félicitations à la lame fusion et
félicitations grand bal était géniale
accueilli avec moi c'est une dame qui
n'a pas besoin de piles poivre un
concurent il s'agit de suzon c36
population de pression mais si nous et
j'espère que vous avez passé d'avoir
accepté de participer avec de grandes
allées de matinée au cap en
hommage à tous ces clans celui qui m'a
formé
monsieur paul david monsieur des souris
kit est à l'origine de la création de
groupes folkloriques martiniquais devenu
des martiniquais ensuite le grand panier
de martiniquais et qui nous a permis de
faire cinq mois de truc du moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]